the nominees for Best Actor are Ernest
Borgnine Marty James Cagney in love me
or leave me James Dean in East of Eden
Frank Sinatra in the man with the Golden
Arm Spencer Tracy in bad day at Black
Rock the winner is
[Applause]
mistake of sounding repetitious I just
want to thank my mother for giving me
the idea of going in and doing this
getting into this wonderful profession
my pup for being steadfast my lovely
wife for helping me thank you very very
much and to the HEC Lancaster
organization I just can't express my
thanks thank you one and all
[Applause]
yeah want to say it's my a nice day
let me put it this way here we are here
we are
mm-hmm amazing isn't it
[Music]
Gracie your name's and all the papers
all over the world you're very famous
young lady and I'm known to be more or
less of a nut well a little bit not not
a whole not a little bit not you know
and I imagine that rope of the audience
during the show tonight and all their
homes and the people here in the
Pantages they're kind of wondering what
is just nuts in the face of this very
nice lady and rather than keep them in
suspense I would like to say on behalf
of myself the motion picture industry
all the nice people who think you're so
nice wish you good luck good health for
a very happy life and god bless you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now if she'd only stopped chasing me
you